>> Female Presenter: Join me in welcoming
to Google, Jane Espenson.
[applause]
>> Jane Espenson: Thank you.
This is fun.
I like being here at Google.
>> Female Presenter: OK, I'm gonna take you
back.
Back.
[laughter]
>> Jane Espenson: Doodoodoodoo.
It's all blurry.
>> Female Presenter: Pre 1992.
>> Jane Espenson: Oh no, OK.
>> Female Presenter: So what were you doing
then?
You were in linguistics.
>> Jane Espenson: I was in grad school.
I was in college from '82 to '92.
>> Female Presenter: Right.
[laughs]
>> Jane Espenson: You've hit the archaeological
level that is my college years.
>> Female Presenter: And what were you working
on there?
>> Jane Espenson: I was working on cognitive
science.
So, I started in computer science added linguistics
as a double major as an undergrad and then
realized, "Hey, linguistics plus computer
science equals cognitive science," which you
can tell isn't a science because it has the
word science in it.
[laughter]
And spent five years doing that in grad school
with George Lakoff.
>> Female Presenter: OK.
So, you went to reality and became a writer.
So, is there anything about your past like,
'82 to '92 about conceptualization of causation
and metaphors that has informed your work?
>> Jane Espenson: I ask myself about that.
For one thing, I needed those years to grow
up.
So, my pseudo-maturity is a result of those
years.
But certainly, the stuff that I like to write
has a metaphorical layer in it.
I don't--.
I'm not particularly interested in writing
household drama.
I like writing sci-fi.
When I write household drama, I like it to
be something like the show "Dinosaurs" that
I worked on, where it's like it's a normal
American household but they're dinosaurs.
[laughter]
I find it allows you to speak more honestly
about what's going on in the world.
So, the events on "Battlestar Galactica" could
have taken place on an ordinary aircraft carrier
on water, but it's much more exciting that
it's an aircraft carrier out in space, in
space.
[laughter]
You can speak about both those shows, Dinosaurs
and "Battlestar Galactica" took on middle
eastern wars as a topic in a way that a show
wouldn't be allowed to if it was like we're
going to do a show about U.S. soldiers.
So we could switch around who was being the
bad guy in any particular episode.
We could move the morality around a bit or
remove it entirely without there being real
world implications we could expose the real
world.
And so, the fact that I like that metaphorical
layer, it's probably not so much that grad
school supplied me with that interest, but
that they were both caused by the same initial
interest in it.
I like the idea of how do we really understand
things.
How do we filter things so that we can grapple
with them?
And that led me both to grad school and to
my interest in sci-fi.
Certainly, my interest in sci-fi predated
grad school.
>> Female Presenter: So now, I'm skipping
a question because you're bringing up the
moral cheat sheet.
>> Jane Espenson: Yes.
>> Female Presenter: And I love that expression.
Not having it in other words.
>> Jane Espenson: Yeah.
This is an idea I had when I went in to speak--.
When you get hired on show they don't just
look at your writing samples and say, "OK.
Show up Monday."
You also have to come in and meet with the
show runner and sometimes that meeting is
very perfunctory.
They know they like your writing.
They know they're inclined to hire you.
They just want to make sure that you're someone
they can stand being in a room with--that
you're not crazy.
So, I call this the "wear pants" meeting.
[laughter]
>> Jane Espenson: If you show up wearing pants
then you're probably OK because they already
like you.
But sometimes you wanna--.
If you really want the job, you wanna go in
armed with some insight about their show.
So, what I came in with at "Battlestar" was
that I admired that it had no moral cheat
sheet.
And Ron, the show runner, leans so far out
in his chair in excitement, I thought he was
going to fall on the floor.
I was like "OK good, I hit something."
Yeah, because that's exactly what he had been
going for.
For so many shows you know that your hero's
not going to make a bad choice, not going
to make an immoral choice.
On "Star Trek", for example, this was always
the way.
So, if Picard was advocating this, unless
he'd been body switched you knew that it was
the right thing to do.
So you could as a viewer sit back and go,
"OK good.
He's doing the right thing."
You didn't have to think about the choice.
Ron came out of the "Star Trek" world and
then created "Battlestar."
And I think it was very much a reaction in
his mind that he wanted to tell stories with
shades of gray that weren't so clear-cut.
And he really loved that I picked up on the
fact that even though we love and respect
President Roslin, we love and respect Admiral
Adama, doesn't mean they're always right.
You don't have a moral cheat sheet to go,
"Oh, who's making the argument?
Adama?
OK.
That's the right thing to do."
He did--.
Made wrong decisions, immoral decisions all
the time.
Sometimes, they were right and immoral.
Sometimes, they were wrong and immoral.
But you had no way of knowing which one it
was going into the argument.
And often, both sides had their merits and
you just had to go, "Which would I do?"
And it was--.
It makes for a much more involving and participatory
show.
And I've thought a lot about what makes a
cult hit, what makes a show with a fandom
where, where the fans are so passionate about
a show that they consider themselves a community.
A lot of that has to do with the degree that
they are engaged with the show.
The amount where it feels participatory for
them.
In an argument in which they are not, being
told passively which side to be on but they
have to actively engage and think about what
side they'd be on.
That's one of the ingredients in the recipe
for cult stardom and "Battlestar's" certainly
achieved that.
I think that's a big part of why.
>> Female Presenter: OK.
So, you prefer writing for TV as opposed to--.
>> Jane Espenson: Oh, yes.
>> Female Presenter: OK.
Why?
>> Jane Espenson: Oh my god.
Movies are awful.
[laughter]
They--.
In TV, we're the boss.
In movies, directors are the boss.
Now that Joss Whedon has gone to movies, what's
he doing?
He's writing and directing.
Because otherwise you are not even on the
set.
Your script is the launching point for visionaries
to come in and imagine a world and the writers
work is done on most movies.
I don't care for that.
On TV, we're the bosses, we create the world,
we make the decisions.
A director is hired week by week, they come
in, sometimes they're fantastic sometimes
they are very visionary.
Sometimes they come back a lot and they become
part of the fabric of the show.
But a lot of times, it's just a guy that comes
in for a week and he has to do what we say.
And if we don't think he's doing it right,
we can fire him.
We have the power.
We sit there on the set.
Technically, if I want to give a note to an
actor, I'm supposed to tell the director and
the director gives that note.
But usually we're sitting in a chair just
like this and I look over and there's an actor
right here saying, "How should I say this?
What did you mean by this or can I do this?"
And I'm just giving them direct instructions.
You'd never have that on a feature set.
Also, features never have to get made.
There's no machine demanding that, "Well,
we've got a time slot.
You said September third; we gotta put it
on the air.
We gotta send it out."
Then stuff gets shoved it gets moved, they
make new decisions.
A new head of studio comes in all those things
are sidelined.
Cabin in the Woods has been done for years.
You know, Joss's amazing new movie.
And it's coming out now.
Luckily it is still fresh as a freshly cut
thing.
[laughter]
Because it's amazing.
It doesn't show the delay but delays happen.
TV is a monster that eats every week, you
need to get stuff on the air.
So I have had six episodes in the last year.
I had six episodes of "Once Upon A Time".
Eleven episodes of "Husbands."
My "Game of Thrones", I guess, was in this
last year.
Just--.
And some other stuff I wrote that hasn't aired
yet for secret projects.
Or you could end up with something ten episodes
eleven, whatever, a year.
Whereas a feature writer can go four years
working on a project and nothing hits the
screen and maybe never will.
Nonsense.
Come to TV.
[laughter]
>>Female Presenter: So you mention "Game of
Thrones."
>> Jane Espenson: Yeah
>> Female Presenter: And the scene to me that
is the most horrific is that golden crown.
>> Jane Espenson: Oooo [laughs]
[laughter]
>>Female Presenter: And you mentioned in one
of the interviews I watched-- I watched many
this weekend-- that you don't write in sequence
necessarily.
Can you talk about that?
>> Jane Espenson: Yeah.
I find that I wanna write the scenes that
I can most strongly visualize first.
And these are usually two person emotional
scenes in which people are sitting down and
talking.
And every script's got some of those.
And they usually are the scenes that make
you cry, that make you feel, and they are
delicate little scenes.
But they are also often the ones you have
most clearly in your head when you sit down
to work.
And you're not--.
You don't have a lot of considerations in
your mind other than pulling the emotion out.
You're not worried about the geography and
who spoke last.
"Is that person been standing silent in the
corner for two pages?"
Like they're--.
I tend to go to those first.
And those tend to give you a pretty good place
to aim at.
Like, you've gotta get the characters to the
emotional states such that they can have that
heart to heart talk.
The last scenes I tend to write are action
and great big group scenes where you've got
seven people in the scene.
Just because there are so many moving parts.
There is so much architecture to figure out.
Like--.
And they're often procedurally scenes.
All you need to know about the fight is who
won because that's what drives you into the
next scene.
So, you can kind of skip that for now.
"Oh, there's a fight and Buffy will win it."
[laughter]
I'll go back later and figure out what she
stabs him with.
[laughs]
[laughter]
But I'm not going to waste brainpower on that
right now when I've still got the big emotional
moment to write.
So, I tend to write out of order.
A lot of authors don't.
A lot of TV writers just go front to back.
On "Game of Thrones", that was totally weird
because it was pre-existing material.
It was an adaptation.
So, I was literally told, the scene, your
episode will go from this page number to that
page number.
So, the first thing I did was go to the book,
look at the scenes, transcribe George R.R
Martin's dialogue and start messing with it
from there.
Because you know the amount of scene that's,
the amount of dialogue that's in one of his
scenes could fill ten pages and it needs to
fill two and a half for the scene.
So, you've gotta pick and choose.
So, there's a lot of work to be done but the--.
All those pivot points, all those big things
are there.
In a certain sense, everything is equal importance
when someone has already done the heavy lifting
and working out the heartbreak.
So that, I think, I really wrote that one
less out of order than anything I've ever
written because the plowing of the field had
been done.
I was just going along planting in the furrows.
[laughter]
>>Female Presenter: Remember that one.
>>Jane Espenson: I just thought of that.
That's pretty good.
[laughter]
>> Female Presenter: Well, Spike was one of
my favorite characters.
Buffy and I like Rumpelstiltskin now, too
a lot.
Do you have characters?
Someone you like writing for?
>> Jane Espenson: Yeah.
Rumple has been amazing because can't go too
far.
I've never dealt with a character who is so
gloriously over the top.
Spike was amazing to write for.
The--.
Even though I don't in real life like bad
boys, they're fun to write for.
Anya I loved writing for because she's so
blunt.
And in a way, she was super easy 'cause you
just had to write what she was thinking, or
to say what she was thinking.
But in another way, it was like finding the
funny thing that she's thinking was more of
a challenge.
I love that.
Willow and all those "Buffy" characters had
such distinct voices.
They were all fun to write for.
I liked writing Giles.
Learned an interesting lesson writing Giles.
We were all--.
We were--.
Season Three, there was a whole new crop of
writers and we were all getting used to writing
these characters that already existed.
I was new.
The show had been around for two years.
And another writer and I were talking about
coming up with British-isms for Giles, making
sure he sounded British.
And Joss pointed out, [coughs] "He sounds
British 'cause he's British."
"You don't have-- it's not a novel, you have
to use the language to convey to the audience
that he's British.
He's going to be British no matter what you
write."
[laughter]
"So, you don't have to work so hard to make
sure he's saying biscuit in every scene."
[laughter]
"Just let him talk and he'll bring the Brit
with him."
And that was a huge lesson.
You forget the difference between writing
for a short story and writing for a screenplay
sometimes, even if you've been doing it a
long time.
But I loved writing--.
"Torchwood" was great.
I got to write--speaking of British stuff--
I got to write all the linguistic confusion
of these Brits in the United States dealing
with, "What do you mean by vest?
"What do you mean by pants?
Why are there so many kinds of milk in the
grocery store?"
There were just great little cultural things
that were really fun to put in.
And writing for Captain Jack and for Gwen
were great.
I've just been really lucky that I've written
for about 15 characters that I could point
at and say Starbuck.
Oh, my God.
And getting to write for Starbuck, amazing.
Oh, and seriously Lannister, Peter Dinklage,
Tyrion.
Oh, my God.
Could there be a clearer more charming and
amoral but moral?
I don't know.
Great, great voices.
I've been very lucky.
>> Female Presenter: That's quite a list.
[laughter]
>> Jane Espenson: I know, yeah, you try to
pick one.
[laughs] Who do you think?
>> Female Presenter: You've got me thinking.
I like all of them.
>> Jane Espenson: Yeah, if you could write
all of those, which one would you want to
write?
>> Female Presenter: Goodness.
Can I come back to that?
>> Jane Espenson: Yeah, OK.
[laughter]
>> Female Presenter: I want to turn to "Husbands"
now.
>> Jane Espenson: Yeah.
>> Female Presenter: So, that's quite brave
of you.
You did that--
>> Jane Espenson: I was terrified.
>>Female Espenson: and you paid for that,
too.
>> Jane Espenson: Yeah that--.
Season One was entirely out of pocket.
Season Two, the fans have put in 50K.
I'm gonna match that 50K.
And we're hoping that there may even be some
sponsor money or something coming in because
we wanna do it that much better.
We wanna upgrade the cameras, get the red
cameras and get better sound, better locations.
We were shooting in a friend's house for Season
One and we had to often choose the take that
didn't have the cat noises in it.
[laughter]
Because there were two pissed off cats locked
in the bathroom of that house while we were
shooting.
[laughter]
And so, there's a lot of takes that just have
this Mrooowwww.
[laughter]
We said we want to rent a house where we can
go and have a genuine production at place.
It turns out, renting a house that these two
guys would have in L.A. is a substantial amount
of money.
We wanna get guest stars and real--.
You wouldn't believe where the money goes--
production insurance, stuff you don't even
think about.
It's like, "Oh, that's how many thousand?"
So, it was very brave.
Thank you for noticing.
Yeah, I was scared to death Season One.
Now Season Two, I'm going in like, "I know
the product turned out well for Season One.
We did not fall on our face."
We did not end up with things that I was,
I was terrified that we'd get a call like,
"Oh we had a glitch; the digital files are
gone.
We didn't get day two of shooting."
That would have killed us.
We wouldn't have been able to do anything.
We didn't have the location anymore.
We couldn't have gone back and re-shot.
We just would have been lost.
So, I just was just trembling with fear every
day.
Now, going in knowing , "OK, I've seen it
work once," we can do this.
>>Female Presenter: Shall we show people?
>> Jane Espenson: Yeah.
You guys wanna see a little of Season One
of "Husbands?"
I'm very, very proud of it.
[laughter]
[applause]
>> Female Presenter: These are scenes picked
for Googlers.
>> Jane Espenson: So, they're very, very short,
little mini episodes.
I'm gonna show you two episodes.
Episode 2 and Episode 11.
The basic storyline is, these two guys haven't
been dating very long, they go to Las Vegas,
they wake up drunk, married.
And they're high enough profile that they've
gotta deal with, what are the implications
of getting a divorce?
So, this is Episode 2.
This is, they have just woken up in the Las
Vegas bathroom and they have noticed they
are wearing wedding rings.
So, this is their--.
How they react--.
Ooo, I want full screen first, this is their
initial reaction to this terrible situation
they find themselves in.
[Jazzy Music]
>> Brady Kelly: No.
No we're too famous for something this fucked
up to happen.
>> Cheeks: "Out athlete and America's gay
sweetheart married during drunken Vegas weekend."
Nah, It's too long for a headline.
See this is why I am an actor not a writer.
>> Brady Kelly: Jesus.
We're going to look bad.
And we're going to make the cause look bad.
And we're gonna look bad.
>> Cheeks: People already kinda expect this
sort of nonsense from me.
>> Brad Kelly: We can't be married.
They're novelty rings in exchange in the spirit
of high camp such as we gays are known for.
>> Cheeks: Satirical performance pop art.
>> Brad Kelly: Yes.
We celebrated marriage equality by getting
fake married Vegas style.
Which is hilarious because we've only dated
six weeks.
>> Cheeks: And for two of those I couldn't
stand you.
>> Brad Kelly: What?
And we know it's fake because if we got real
married we need a license, and I don't see
the license.
>>Cheeks: There may be a document in my pants.
>> Brad Kelly: Certificate of marriage.
It's notarized.
Oh we drunk notarized.
OK, OK, OK, OK, OK, OK, OH.
>>Cheeks: Use your words.
>> Brad Kelly: Annulment.
Marriages can be annulled if you're too drunk
to know what you're doing.
My teammates do it all the time.
>> Cheeks: So, that's why you're called the
Dodgers.
Wrong time but it's comedy gold.
>> Brad Kelly: I'm serious.
If we act fast and no one finds out, it's
as is if never happened.
>> Cell phone voice: Google alert.
>> Cheeks: It's a Google alert.
It's about us.
Is that how you spell travesty?
>> Brad Kelly: Yeah.
>> Cheeks: Are you sure?
>> Brad Kelly: I won a spelling bee once.
>> Cheeks: Really?
So much to learn about each other.
[Jazzy Music]
>> Jane Espenson: And this is the very last
episode, the very last episode.
So, they've been through a bunch of stuff
and they're dealing with a little last second
panic conflict before they settle in and realize
that maybe this will work after all.
[Jazzy music]
[Dryer noise]
>> Cheeks: This is because I didn't update
my relationship status on Google Plus?
[Dryer door slams]
>> Brad Kelly: Yeah.
>> Cheeks: I didn't think about it.
>> Brad Kelly: Yeah I figured.
Now that you're aware maybe you could.
>> Cheeks: Sure.
Next time I'm online.
[ Huffs ] Yeah and I'm the girl.
Select, married, done.
>> Brad Kelly: Thank,s babe.
I really do think you--.
>> Cheeks: Hold on, I'm updating my status.
Home with hubby, smiley face.
>> Brad Kelly: Oh, that's sweet.
>> Cheeks: Hang on I'm Tweeting.
Hash tag, k-i-s my h-u-b.
>> Brad Kelly: Mmmhm I get what you're--.
>> Cheeks: I'm emailing it--
>> Brad Kelly: OK--
>> Cheeks: Tagging--.
>> Brad Kelly: Cheeks--.
>> Cheeks: Tumbling--.
>> Brad Kelly: Will you--.
>> Cheeks: And Digg.
Ok.
Now, what was it you wanted to talk about?
>> Brad Kelly: I just--.
I wanna--.
>> Cheeks: OH, hang on we need to Twit-pic
the new tattoo above my ass that says, "Mrs.
Brady Kelly."
Smiley face.
>> Brad Kelly: Done?
Because I get it.
I- I've got a better idea.
How about we stop talking and get into bed,
and find something else to do.
>> Cheeks: Winky face.
[Piano Music]
>> Brad Kelly: So, we're really married.
Like for realsies.
>> Cheeks: Yes.
It's beautiful and politically necessary.
>> Brad Kelly: And I love you.
You said I should surprise you with--.
>> Cheeks: Flawless execution.
I love you, too.
>> Brad Kelly: Hey, Cheeks.
>> Cheeks: Yes, darling?
>> Brad Kelly: What's your real name?
[Jazzy Music]
>> Jane Espenson: So, we mentioned Goggle
twice and we didn't even know we were coming
here.
[laughter]
>> Female Presenter: I think it's time for
our questions.
>> Jane Espenson: Sure.
>> male#1: In general how does writing for
a TV series work?
For example, between the credited screenwriter
for that episode, and the more permanent creative
team running the show?
Who's responsible for which decisions, and
how do they work together?
>> Jane Espenson: Great, great question.
You work in a room.
Every day I go to work and I go to a room
and it's full of funny people, and we sit
there and we break an episode.
So, we know what episode's coming up next.
We know the story, general story usually that
we wanna tell in it.
And it becomes--.
It comes down to the show runner guiding a
discussion.
In my current show, "Once Upon a Time" we
have twin show runners.
Not really, they're partners and they run
the show together.
And so they will say, "Ok we wanna do a Cinderella
story this week.
And we sort of figure it's probably about
this."
First thing we talk about is, what's the theme
of it?
What are we trying to say with this episode?
That's really important.
Shows that don't start out there often sort
of fail to get one of the important ingredients
in making a cult hit.
Which is, that people have to feel that there's
a reason to watch it.
That there's a reason to tell the stories.
So, start with theme, and it could be as simple
as love conquers all.
Doesn't have to be deep, but it has to be
real.
Has to be something you really believe.
And then, you start figuring out "Ok well
what's going to happen to her?
We think she's gonna come up against this
bad guy, and we think at the end she'll be
in this place."
And you start working it out by act breaks.
Act breaks are the moments that go into each
commercial.
There always used to be four acts in a TV
show.
Now we're up to six.
There's been some act inflation 'cause then
they get more commercial breaks.
So, you've gotta figure out a story that can
turn that many times.
So, stories have actually gotten perhaps a
little shallower in the last few years because
you have to--.
You're just getting your feet under you in
an act and you've gotta turn the story.
You've gotta come up with that big dramatic
"Hey this isn't what we thought.
You have to do it more often."
If you work on a show, like "Game of Thrones"
you don't have to do that because you don't
have commercial breaks so it's very different.
But--.
So, the show runner's responsibility is guiding
that discussion.
At a certain point, you've filled up a white
board with all the details of all the scenes
that are going to go in this episode.
In which order and which ones are right before
act breaks.
And at a certain point, you declare it broken.
Which means it's fixed.
[laughter]
And someone--.
One of the writers is sent home to write it.
That's when that writer, that writer's had
a responsibility of participating in the room,
pitching ideas, pitching lines, like saying
things as little as " I think he should put
cinnamon in his coffee."
It was a big discussion early on, of whether
characters should bond over something they
don't like in the coffee shop or something
they do like in the coffee shop.
It's a tiny, tiny point.
But that you know your contribution could
be that small.
Or, you could have said, "Actually I don't
think this is the week to do Cinderella because
I just had an idea that is a whole different
idea."
So, you participated in the room, but your
work to me really starts when you're sent
home and you've got this beat sheet, this
list of the scenes and what's going to happen
in each of them.
And you have to turn that around and come
back with a 52-page document with every decision
filled in, every line of dialogue written.
That's your main duty as a writer.
Now on most shows, writers, particularly higher-level
writers, are also producers, so you theoretically
you go to the set.
You go to show and tell with the prop guy
and you say, "No, not that cigarette lighter,
that one."
And you go to costumes and you say, "I do
not like that hat," or whatever it is that
you're saying, and then you sit on set and
you sit with the director and you say things
like, "I don't think we got it.
That performance wasn't quite right."
Whatever.
But it's very cold.
The set's a tedious place to be.
And on our particular show, our set is up
in Vancouver and we don't go up.
So, our job pretty much ends when you turn
in that draft of the script.
So, the prod--.
The executive producers, though, have to be
worried about everything.
They have to fly up to Vancouver and look
at the hats.
They have to deal with the manager of the
actor that's calling.
They have to talk with ABC marketing about
the posters and what gift they are going to
give at Comicon.
And whether they should be inviting the press
in to talk to them about the mid-season episode.
They're deciding lots and lots of stuff that
has nothing to do with the, what's the next
line or dialogue in the script.
This is the reason I really like being a writer.
I don't know, does that answer your questions
about the different responsibilities?
'Cause there's a lot of different other ways--.
Oh I can also talk about younger writers versus
more experiences writers.
When you're hired, you're hired as a staff
writer.
Built into your contract is a series of promotions.
Your next season you will be a story editor
even though you're not editing anything.
You're doing the exact same thing you did
as a staff writer.
The next year you're executive story editor,
then you're co-producer.
And you may think, "Ahh, that's the jump to
producer."
No, co means not--.
[laughter]
Co-producer not a producer.
Step after that is producer.
Then you're a producer.
Then supervising producer.
We lost some light.
[laughs] And so, you move up through these
links of these insane titles all of which
are just different kinds of writers.
And you're producing duties may or may not
expand as your title goes up.
>> Male#2: So, where did you want to go with
"Caprica?"
>> Jane Espenson: Where did I want to go with
"Caprica" was handed to me, I was not involved
in the conception of it.
I really knew nothing about it.
I hadn't seen the pilot.
The casting was all done, the hiring of the
staff was essentially done, and I was brought
in to write it with --. Or not write it, to
run it with Ron Moore.
So, we had an initial sit down with Ron Moore
where he sort of laid out where it would go.
And I did my best to stick to where he wanted
it to go.
>> Male#2: So, you didn't have your own ambition
before Kevin Murphy came in or anything?
>> Jane Espenson: I had my thoughts about
what characters I felt were working with story-lines
I felt were working.
I was working within a big team.
David Eick was there also as executive producer.
SyFy has a lot of authority over their shows.
So, I was part of a group that was steering
it in directions.
I think the show turned out remarkably well
for having so many cooks.
[laughs] Yeah, it was.
It was a little hard to know exactly where
it was going.
I think it was, as most Season One shows do,
even though it was continuation sort of a
"Battlestar" universe.
It was also Season One of a show with a very
different feel to it.
We were a domestic drama with robots.
[laughter]
And so, I think there wasn't huge anonymity
of decision about exactly where it should
go.
And then to a certain extent, I think it was
kept open on purpose.
Let's see what's working, let's see what's
not working.
So, if you are implying that there may be
a feeling of a lack of a unified vision, I
think that's probably true.
>> Male#2: And a second quick question.
How is it in the "Husbands" comedy that the
one man didn't know his husbands real name
when he had a Google+ account?
[laughter]
>>Jane Espenson: Cheeks, Cheeks signed up
for the Google+ account with the name Cheeks.
He also looks at his own marriage license
and didn't see his real name.
We had that marriage license printed up so
it just says Cheeks.
[laughs] So, I think it's like Cher.
I think Cheeks has had his name legally changed.
[laughter]
>> Female Presenter: So, there's a question
right here.
>> Female#1: So, I wanted to tell you how
much I love your work.
>> Jane Espenson: Thank you.
>> Female#1: Noticing your name in the credits
was sort of a starting point for me in realizing
that there were writers were making these
characters say these things.
Which is odd because I had, at one point,
thought I would pursue writing as a career.
And I realized that over time I kept seeing
these characters who were making me feel things
and your name kept popping into the credits.
>> Jane Espenson: Aww.
>> Female#1: And I would watch the DVD content
and realized I would listen to the things
you were saying about the characters.
I realized this wasn't an accident, that there
are really writers who really shape and inform
how we experience TV.
And with the internet right now, that's really
changing.
I see what you are doing with "Kickstarter"
and I'm excited about this project.
And I can directly connect to you and inspire
this project to happen because of a writer
I believe in.
So, I'd really like to hear from you about
where new media is taking things in terms
of the current action.
It's not just the actor anymore who's the
visible presence.
So, I'd love to hear from you.
>> Jane Espenson: So many fizzy, fizzy thoughts
coming after that.
Number one of which is, the experience you
described I had pre social media.
Which is I read an interview with April Kelly
who was a "MASH" writer.
And seeing the woman's name talking about
writing for "MASH" is what made me go, "that's
a thing I can do."
So, I'm glad I could do that 'cause that was
done for me.
And I'm so thrilled that that's your view
of the "Kickstarter" because I was actually
very reluctant to do it 'cause I knew I could
put in money.
I didn't want to take money from people who
have less money than me.
I was putting in all I could afford, but I
know that people might be scraping around
for their ten dollar bill to give, and I didn't
want that.
That would hurt my soul.
And so, when we realized that we could give
incentives, that would make it worthwhile
for people so they would get something of
value.
And we also realized that giving them a Season
Two, a high quality Season Two, was something
that would make it worth it.
And beyond that, the sense that they're involved
in it.
That's what really surprised me and made me
thrilled, was that people were enjoying giving
because they felt like they got to be part
of the team.
And they got to support a project they believed
in, they got to support marriage equality,
they get to support good comedy, they get
to support online content.
There's a whole bunch of stuff you get to
support.
And the "Kickstarter" is still sittin' up
there.
Go to "Kickstarter" look for "Husbands" we're
Every dollar we get will help us make it more
and better and bigger.
But yeah that's-- and yeah that future of
social media, that fact that crowd funding
now makes it possible to do for even, for
anyone with a dream and good big idea to get
out there, raise some money, make something
on your own.
But I gotta think that online is where the
future of the new wave of content is going
to come from.
And because you don't have to be a broadcaster,
you don't have to appeal to everyone in every
demographic, you can take risks.
You can do a show like ours with this young,
sexy married couple.
TV will put gay marrieds on TV but they generally
won't make them sexual.
They do everything to desexualize them.
They cast a straight actor as one of the guys,
or they give them babies or something.
As much as I love "Modern Family", I love
"Modern Family."
But there is a certain trend to make you not
think that these guys are having hot sex.
And our show is all about, these are newlyweds,
of course they are.
But they are still making every mistake that
every other newlywed couple does.
All newlyweds do.
So, we wanted, we wanted to do content that
was a little spicy, a little intriguing.
Something you can't get everywhere else.
And online is totally the place to do it and
I just have a feeling even though right now
this is a mechanism for us to feed money into
a system.
I gotta think ultimately online will become
a place where it isn't just a one way thing
where someone's gonna crack the code for figuring
out how to make this a legitimate two way
conversation between us and the audience.
>>Male#3: One of the things on the flyer there,
in fact the headline, introducing you there
is that you are a "Hugo Award" winning author
for your work on "Buffy."
>>Jane Espenson: Right.
>>Male #3: You're probably not aware that
it was actually controversy when they created
a category for the "Hugo Awards"--
>> Jane Espenson: Ohhhh.
>> Male#3: that was primarily aimed at television
shows.
There used to only be just one that covered
movies and TV, and it mostly went to movies.
>> Jane Espenson: Right.
>> Male #3: Some of the criticisms of it were
actually, "Oh there's no reason just to create
a category just for "Buffy."
Because at the time--
[laughter]
Now as it happens--
>> Jane Espenson: Nice.
[laughter]
>> Male #3: Now there's no need for a category
just for "Doctor Who."
>> Jane Espenson: Right, right.
>>Male #3: But had you been familiar --. Had
you heard of the award even before you received
it?
And was--?
>> Jane Espenson: Oh, "Hugo?"
Yeah.
>> Male #3: was it worth--?
One of the major criticisms from within the
"World Science Fiction Society" is, "well,
nobody in movie and television ever pays attention
to that.
They don't really give a darn about that."
>> Jane Espenson: Oh.
>> Male#3: Was that worthwhile did you think?
>> Jane Espenson: Yeah.
Oh my "Hugo," that's all I really have.
I have half a "Hugo" and two "Streamies,"
and that's all I have because sci-fi stuff
is generally not recognized in Hollywood.
And so, to have the "Hugos" recognize it is
like our only way to get legitimacy.
The "Battlestar Galactica" won-- what was
that?
What's the really fancy one?
>> Male#3: "Saturnite"
>> Jane Espenson: No "Saturn" is not fancy.
[laughter]
>> Male#3: I've never seen one.
>> Jane Espenson: "Saturn" is adorable and
I would love one 'cause I don't have one.
But the one like a--.
It was like--.
It wasn't a "Bradbury."
Anyway it was a--.
>> Male#4: [inaudible]
>>Jane Espenson: No, no.
It wasn't even a science fiction award.
It was like an award for being genius media
in a mainstream kind of world.
We'll figure it out, someone will look it
up.
But--.
>> Male#5: [inaudible]
>> Jane Espenson: I know.
[laughter]
>> Jane Espenson: Somebody pull your phone
out.
What did "Battlestar Galactica--?"
But they won it the year before I was there
so, I don't have it.
But yes, those awards carry big clout in Hollywood
because those, the showbiz awards, everybody
knows them; everybody has them.
The non-showbiz awards are like, " Oh you're
legit; you've broke-- the real people, the
smart people gave you the award."
[laughter]
"Hugo Award" is huge.
"Hugo Award" is bigger than any of them.
I am so pleased with it.
>> Male#3: I'll bring that up anytime someone
criticizes it.
>> Jane Espenson: Yeah, no, don't criticize
it.
And I was--.
>> Male#3: Suggested was the "Peabody" that
you--.
>> Jane Espenson: "Peabody" thank you.
>> Male#3: By the way, I was sympathetic to
your talking about with "Husbands," the worries
about filming in a house and so on.
When I was in college, we did--.
Our science fiction club filmed two one- hour
long "Doctor Who" fan movies and it was the
same thing.
In a house, we're about to lose the light,
that kind of thing.
I know.
>> Jane Espenson: Oh, it's so hard.
Stuff that you don't--.
I learned so much doing web content as opposed
to big TV, about things that you don't think
about on the set, like feeding the crew.
[laughter]
That sort of happens automatically.
But on the web series I'm stopping at Taco
Bell and ordering 20 burritos at the drive-thru
before I go to set 'cause somebody's gotta
feed 'em.
And just, "Oh, wait, nobody remembered to
bring the champagne glass.
Well, we have an enormous margarita glass.
That's funnier anyway."
[laughter]
Great happenstance, but also great panic if
we don't have.
There are two scenes in this in which Shawn
forgot, who plays Brady, forgot his shoes.
So, he's shoeless in a couple scenes and you
just don't pan down enough to see it.
But yeah, just things happen and I also learned
a big thing about being in the editing room,
which is on all previous projects I thought
if a line had to be cut or something had to
be changed in the editing room I felt like,
" yeah that's was a problem with the script
I should have caught it at the script stage."
Now I go "No, there was no problem with the
script; this is how it had to be.
Having the script a certain way got a certain
performance, now we cut it out in the editing
room.
That is the best way to have made this moment
happen."
You don't-- it, really is the next pass.
I had heard that, I'd never believed it.
So, it's something a lot of people learn in
film school, I'm just learning now.
>> Female Presenter: OK, I think we have a
yellow question.
Yes.
>> Jane Espenson: Yes.
>> Female#2: Hi, my name is Tricia.
One thing I've always liked about your shows,
they tend to pass the Bechdel Test with flying
colors.
>> Jane Espenson: Yeah.
>> Female#2: And I was wondering if this was
a coincidence.
And if it's not, is it something you have
to fight for?
And have you ever encountered resistance to
having multiple female protagonists in a scene,
in an episode, or even in a show premise?
>> Jane Espenson: You do what you can in the
writers room.
Depending on the room that you're in.
you may reach some resistance if there's a
scene with two girls and they're talking about
a guy you can say, "Have you guys heard of
the Bechdel Test?"
That's often how I do it 'cause then they
feel like it's not just me and an agenda.
It's like, fans are gonna notice and then
sometimes that pays it that, that will help.
But I haven't actually faced that in a long
time.
If you look at "Once Upon A Time," we just
have so many lead females with Regina, Mary
Margaret, and Snow, I mean, no I doubled one
up.
Snow is Mary Margaret, and Emma.
It's impossible for them to be giggling about
boys in every scene.
So, there's just tons and tons and tons of
Bechdel falling left and right.
We had one who worried me a little bit when
we had Snow and Red Riding Hood talking about
their men.
And it was Snow going "I think you like this
guy, what are you gonna do?
You gonna run away with him?"
That scene turns into "let's go kill a wolf."
[laughter]
So, after a while I calmed down and I was
like, you know what?
This one passes.
[laughs] And you don't want to be so crazy
to it that nobody can ever talk about relationships
because relationships are at the heart of
a lot of people's lives.
So I try to always keep it in mind that sometimes
you get it in and sometimes you don't.
Yeah.
>> Female#2: Something that makes it unique
is that it's not that the relationships are
the only reason the woman's in the show.
>> Jane Espenson: Right.
>> Female#2: "Buffy" was ultimately a show
about a woman who had a job fighting demons.
>> Jane Espenson: Absolutely.
And there were other important decisions beyond
Bechdel in how Buffy was treated.
Joss made really sure that nobody ever challenged
her ability to lead on the basis that she
was a woman or a girl.
Whatever she was.
It was--.
They might challenge her on other reasons
like you're exhausted, you're crazy, you're
infected with a demon spawn, or whatever.
[laughter]
But it was never "you're a woman."
And similarly, on "Battlestar Galactica,"
President Roslin was never challenged on that
basis.
And I love that Ron set up a world in which
there was not a history of gender discrimination.
And in fact, when I got to write the "Face
of the Enemy" web series, I co-wrote those,
in which we learn that Lieutenant Gaeta is
gay.
Although I hate to even use that word gay
in the "Battlestar Galactica" universe because
they don't seem to have a word.
Because it's just that.
Some people love here and some people love
there.
They've never thought of separating them out
and giving them a different name.
But we learn that in that episode and I tried
really hard to write that so that this-- nobody
was shocked by that.
There's actually a shot in it of Colonel Tigh
giving, looking askance.
That wasn't intended to be a "you've got a
boyfriend?"
That was intended to be like "how come I didn't
know you had a relationship with another crew
member?"
So, I hope people read that in the way it
was intended.
That writing a show, that what a great freedom
it is and that it's another way to apply metaphor.
It's kinda like, here's our world as seen
if this had, if we didn't have this in our
history.
Look what's the same, look what corresponds,
look what's different.
I love that.
>> Male#6: All right.
This one is from Tricia Weir.
If you could choose any show you've ever worked
on and retcon it out of cancellation with
a new season,
[laughter]
which show would it be?
>> Jane Espenson: I-- it's interesting 'cause
sometimes that doesn't mean it's the show
you love best.
I don't think, I think "Buffy" ended well
and has been continued in the comic book.
So that would be a weird one to go back and
continue.
Where do you continue it from?
The end of the current comic book season?
"Torchwood" ended too soon.
I mean, we don't know if there's going to
be more "Torchwood."
Russell's dealing with stuff.
But I would love to see more "Torchwood."
Obviously there would-- "Once Upon a Time"
I'm certain will continue.
So that one's good.
I'm getting to make more "Husbands."
"Firefly."
"Firefly" deserved more.
"Firefly" ended too soon, had stories left
to tell, Joss was excited about the--.
That's why he made "Serenity" it's like there
was more to do.
I would love, love, love to write another
season of "Firefly."
>> Male#6: Why in God's name, this is my question,
was "Firefly" canceled so soon?
>> Jane Espenson: I--.
Yeah I actually don't know.
I don't think I could if I did know.
But I think it just was probably a mismatch
between what FOX was finding profitable on
their airwaves.
That was still a time when ratings triumphed
over DVD sales.
The studio makes the DVD money.
The network sells the advertising.
So they, the network cares about the ratings.
You can be huge in DVD sales and the network
may not even know about it or care about it.
So, I think studios in which the studio and
the network are all one entity, this sort
of happens at SyFy more, I think they're more
likely to keep a DVD hit show around.
Then FOX was, 'cause I don't know that they
cared about the cult following.
They were just looking at the weekly numbers
and I am sure they were probably, in their
spreadsheets, they were probably right.
The numbers didn't justify it.
I think there were more numbers they weren't
seeing.
But I'm guessing.
>> Male#6: So, you're telling me short term
thinking killed "Firefly?"
>> Jane Espenson: Short-term thinking killed
a lot.
Yeah.
>> Male#6: All right, and I have one more
question for you off the Dory for you.
This is from some dude named Dan Block, and
the question is, "your website says you wear
very bright colors.
Are you sure about that?"
[laughter]
>> Jane Espenson: [laughs] I generally do.
When I come to an appearance like this, I
try to class it up.
So--.
But I don't know that I've ever even worn
this black blouse before.
Normally I'm in very, very bright colors.
But it--.
I like to think it's reflected in my writing.
I always try to put humor in anything I write,
even a dark show.
But today I'm giving you dark Jane.
[laughter]
>> Male#7: Just a question on the business
of writing.
You've given some perspective on what really
happens when a show runner kinda goes forward
with everything.
When you look at a show that becomes a big
success and writers kinda disperse to other
shows, it seems that, that unified vision
you spoke of earlier seems to deviate.
And I think a good example is something like
maybe "Lost," where--
>> Jane Espenson: Mmmhmm.
>> Male #7: they clearly had a vision that
over time, they really deviated from that
just because from my perspective, it just
seems like a lot of the writers kinda jump
ship and kinda did their own thing.
But is that how it normally happens in Hollywood?
>> Jane Espenson: I thought you were going
to ask different question so my mind's still
there.
Shows sometimes weaken over age and sometimes
because people leave.
Sometimes they get stronger over age because
someone comes in with a great strong vision
and reinvigorates it or vigorates it.
So I think it really matters show to show.
Trying to think of a show.
I worked on "Ellen."
And "Ellen," the first season of "Ellen" was
called "These Friends of Mine."
And then they fired all the writers and they
got rid of a bunch of cast members, and it
came back as "Ellen" and then it sort of stumbled
along with an eleven rating for a while.
And then they were like, "Oh, she wants to
come out let's incorporate it in that show."
Oh, my god.
A season of huge, huge, huge ratings.
The show found itself.
The show was about something.
Then my--.
Then they were all fired.
New staff came in.
[laughter]
I don't know where they went actually, they
may have just all, I don't know what happened.
But I came in for the season after she came
out.
We were telling great stories.
The show had a reason to exist, which it never
had before.
It never had a hook.
It was just a girl in a coffee shop, and then
suddenly the bookstore.
So we had a reason to tell--.
We were telling exciting stories.
Stories that had never been told before.
But eventually the numbers went back down
to the eleven.
The show went back to its rating of the people
who really loved it and loved her.
So it went away.
But I felt like that was a show that got stronger
because somehow you found a thing for the
show to be about.
So, I think lots of different things can happen.
Shows have a lifespan.
A lot of shows have about five seasons in
them, and then they go away.
I mean, British TV takes us to an extreme.
Well there's about six episodes in this show,
let's do that.
So sometimes, it's about shows outliving their
natural lifespan.
The story's done, let's make more story.
But what I thought you were gonna talk about
it the way a show can have an academy in it
that's so strong, the writers can learn so
much, that they then-- when they go to other
shows, they take that philosophy with them.
Which is what happened to "Buffy."
Because almost all the "Buffy" writers are
now running shows or doing other big things
in other shows.
And they all brought with them the core of
the Joss beliefs about, make me feel, make
this about something.
What does this mean to the main character?
Go deeper.
Make your genres.
Make funny in your sadness, put sadness in
your funny.
Walk away with those things and any show you
go to you're gonna bring those to.
And so, the "Buffy" explosion sent "Buffy"
stardust out into the universe.
[laughter]
>> Female Presenter: I think we have time
for one last question.
>> Male#7: Yeah.
What are some of your favorite shows that
you didn't write or perhaps wish you could
partake in writing?
>> Jane Espenson: Oh.
"MASH."
[laughter]
Where have you gone?
"Lou Grant," "Mary Tyler Moore," "Bob Newhart,"
"The Odd Couple."
A lot of the shows from my childhood that
I grew up watching and imagining, including
the stupid shows.
"Welcome Back, Kotter."
"The Love Boat."
[laughter]
"What's Happening?"
I had stories in my head for those shows and
never got to write them.
I would have loved to have written an episode
of "The Wire."
I would love to have written, so many good
shows that I would love to get my teeth in.
Sometimes a really dark show, maybe like "Breaking
Bad" or something where it's like I would
love to see how much humor I could get in
there.
How much can it bear?
That was my favorite thing to do on "Battlestar,"
was to take a really dark scene and see if
I could put a joke in it.
Because that joke is gonna play twisted, sick,
and even darker than if I hadn't made a joke.
[laughter]
And so, I loved that there was a scene where
everyone is talking about how everyone is
so starving on the ship that they're eating
paper.
And then eventually they stop eating paper.
Why is that?
Paper shortage.
[laughter]
That kills me 'cause it's just so sad.
[laughs]
[laughter]
And yet it's got the structure of a joke.
I love that.
So I'd love to pick something really dark
but right now, I'd love to write a "Community"
or something but I don't have the chops.
I feel like--.
I come out of comedy.
I spent a lot of years writing comedy.
That show's so good.
I can't touch that.
I would be writing, I feel, a lesser species.
Give me a dramatic show and let me put some
fun in it.
So what's the darkest thing out there right
now?
Point me at it.
I'll do it.
>> Female Presenter: Well, thank you very
much for coming to Google today.
>> Jane Espenson: Thank you.
[applause]